,
REDHEAD OF TRUMP, IT MAKES YOU
WONDER ABOUT HIS FUTURE.
>> Jesse: SOMETIMES, IN CABLE,
DATA, YOU JUST SAY THINGS.
>> Dana: I WAS GOING TO SAY --
[LAUGHTER]
GET A LITTLE REACTION.
TO BE ON ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS --
>> Dana: AND NO CONSEQUENCES.
>> Greg: THERE SHOULD BE.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO SAY STUPID
STUFF LIKE THAT.
I SAY AT LEAST SIX STUPID THINGS
A DAY --
>> Jesse: THIS SEGMENT.
>> Dana: JUST PUT IT OUT
THERE.
>> Jesse: PROVOCATIVE, GREG.
>> Dana: FOR THE STORIES ARE
ON DOUG EMHOFF TRYING TO RALLY
THE TROOPS BEHIND KAMALA HARRIS,
THEY REPORTEDLY MET WITH ROLLING
EYES IN THE WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE,
FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD NEVER WANT
MY HUSBAND TO DO THAT FOR ME.
IF YOU ARE NOT -- IF PEOPLE ARE
NOT GROWLING AT AROUND YOU, YOU
CANNOT HAVE YOUR HUSBAND -- WE
HAVE NEVER HAD A SECOND
GENTLEMAN BEFORE, BUT I ASSUME
IF THE PEOPLE IN THE WEST WING
AREN'T TAKING HER SERIOUSLY, HOW
SERIOUSLY ARE THEY TAKING HIM?
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW COUPLES
WHERE THE HUSBAND REALLY
ENCOURAGES THE WIFE'S CAREER AND
IT IS NOT REALLY TAKE OFF.
>> Greg: SECOND GENTLEMAN
SOUNDS LIKE THE TITLE OF, LIKE,
A CINEMAX -- REMEMBER CINEMAX,
THOSE LATE-NIGHT SIX?
MAY BE A ROMANCE COVER WITH FAR
BEYOND THE COVER.
>> Dana: STACEY ABRAMS MIGHT
WANT TO WORK ON IT.
>> Greg: I AM MORE INTERESTED
IN HOW FETTERMAN HAS RUINED THE
LOOK OF THE HOODIE FOR ME.
I USED TO LIKE TO WEAR A HOODIE
BUT WHEN YOU START WEARING IT IN
INAPPROPRIATE PLACES, IT KIND OF
STAINED ITS BEAUTY SO THAT IS
WHEN I'M NOT VOTING FOR HIM FOR
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: DO YOU WANT TO TAKE
ON, JUDGE, FETTERMAN FOR
PRESIDENT LINE, OR DO YOU WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE DUDE, THE
SECOND DUDE?
>> Jeanine: I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT KAMALA.
HOW COULD HE PUSH HER?
SHE HAS THE LOWEST APPROVAL
RATINGS, DID NOT EVEN MAKE IT TO
THE IOWA CAUCUSES, THE WOMAN HAS
BEEN GIGGLING LIKE SHE HAS BEEN
LAUGHING THE WHOLE TWO YEARS SO
FAR.
SHE HASN'T SAID ANYTHING SMART.
AND SHE JUST GIGGLES.
EVERY PICTURE, I MEAN, IT IS SO
DISAPPOINTING FOR WOMEN.
EMHOFF, I DON'T KNOW WHO HE IS,
I DON'T CARE WHO HE IS ABOUT I
DON'T THINK SHE IS GOING
ANYWHERE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT FETTERMAN, THE
GUY CANNOT GET OUT OF HIS OWN
WAY BUT IT WORKS FOR A DEMOCRAT.
IF YOU'RE NOT A QUALITY
CANDIDATE ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
YOU, YOU DO NOT GET ELECTED, BUT
IF YOU ARE AN IDIOT WHO HIDES
EITHER IN A TROJAN HORSE LIKE
JOE BIDEN OR FETTERMAN OR,
WHAT'S HER NAME, KATIE HOBBS,
YOU GET ELECTED.
>> Jesse: THE BEST FETTERMAN
LINE, WHILE THE RHYTHM OF TO
SUPPORT FRACKING?
HE IS LIKE, YES.
YOU USED TO NOT SUPPORT
FRACKING.
HE WAS LIKE, I SUPPORT FRACKING.
GREAT CANDIDATE, RIGHT.
>> Jessica: YEAH COME IN A LOT
OF WAYS, HE WAS.
IF YOU WATCH THE PRIMARY PLAY
OUT, I WAS SUPPORTIVE OF CONOR
LAMB, I THOUGHT HE WAS THE
BETTER CHOICE FOR IT, BUT --
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
L.A.M.B. WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
CRUSHED.
FETTERMAN, THAT IS THE GUY YOU
WANT.
>> Jeanine: I WANT TO HEAR
FROM A DEMOCRAT WOMAN, WHAT YOU
THINK OF KAMALA, IS SHE
PRESIDENTIAL MATERIAL?
>> Jessica: SHE HAS
VICE PRESIDENTIAL MATERIAL.
LISTEN, I HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN
MS, KAMALA HARRIS WAS NOT MY
CHOICE IN THE PRIMARY, HE WAS
NOT THE CHOICE AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE, GO AND VOTE, WHY SHE
DROPPED OUT FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE HUGE HILLARY CLINTON
SUPPORTERS, AND IT WAS A BIG
ISSUE THAT DID NOT FEEL SHE WAS
WORTHY OF THAT MANTLE, THAT SHE
WAS AS STRONG A CANDIDATE AS
HILLARY CLINTON WAS, BUT WHAT I
WILL SAY, EVERYONE ALWAYS TALKS
ABOUT HER, WHAT DOES SHE DO?
SHE DOESN'T GET ANYTHING DOES
COME SHE IS IN CHARGE OF THE
BORDER, ROOT CAUSES, YOU KNOW
WHAT ISSUE SHE WAS IN CHARGE OF?
ABORTION.
SHE WAS THE ONE WHO IS OUT FRONT
IN THE ADMINISTRATION, TALKING
ABOUT THE THREAT TO WOMEN,
ESPECIALLY --
>> Greg: WHAT A STRETCH.
>> Jesse: YOU GET ALL THE
CREDIT, KAMALA.
>> Jessica: PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
JOE BIDEN'S LEGACY, THEY TALK
ABOUT SAME-SEX MARRIAGE AND HE
WAS IN CHARGE OF THAT.
>> Jesse: THE CRIMES HE HAS
COMMITTED OVERSEAS.
>> Jessica: YOU DO, BUT NORMAL
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT --
>> Jesse: WHAT DOES THE SECOND
GENTLEMAN DO ALL DAY?
>> Jessica: THE SAME THING
WHEN A LADY DOES THE JOB --
HE PEES STANDING UP, THAT IS
DIFFERENT.
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T HAVE
OTHER THINGS GOING ON?
>> Jessica: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> Jesse: I JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHAT HE DOES ALL DAY.
>> Greg: THIS IS FOR
"PRIME TIME."
>> Jesse: WE ARE GOING TO LOOK